Speaker 1: Okay, so let's now move away from
the unsourced conspiracy smears against Cassidy
Hutchinson, the January six committee
witness. And let's look at a specific
claim that's being made about something she said
that is allegedly not true. There are now reports
that the note that was put up on the screen during
Cassidy Hutchinson's testimony, which she said,
I wrote that that's my handwriting. There is a
contradictory claim being made that that is not
her handwriting. So let's evaluate this. This
would be this is specific and substantive. So
and it's sourced. So there's no issue here
with evaluating it, ABC News reports. Trump
White House Attorney Disputes Cassidy Hutchinson's
testimony about a handwritten note. Former Trump
White House lawyer Eric Hershman is claiming that
a handwritten note regarding a potential statement
for then-President Donald Trump to release during
the January six attack was written by him during
a meeting at the White House that afternoon,
not by Cassidy Hutchinson, sources familiar
with the matter tell ABC News. So what's this all
about? At Tuesday's January six committee hearing,
Liz Cheney displayed a note, which Hutchinson
said. I wrote that she said she saw it and she
said, That's my handwriting. I wrote that. Sources
familiar with the matter say that Eric Hershman,
an attorney, had previously told the committee he
wrote the note. A spokesperson for Hirschman said
to ABC News Tuesday night, quote, The handwritten
note that Cassidy Hutchinson testified was written
by her was in fact, written by Eric Hirschman
on January six, 2021. All sources with direct
knowledge and law enforcement have and will
confirm that it was written by Mr. Hirschman.
At the hearing on Tuesday, Hutchinson testified
about the note, quote, That's a note that I wrote
at the direction of the chief of staff on January
six. Likely around 3:00, Liz Cheney asked. And
it's written on the chief of Staff note card. But
that's your handwriting. Ms.. Hutchinson. And Ms..
Hutchinson said, That's my handwriting. Okay. This
is a specific disagreement, and it is not really
subject to the squishiness of some of the other
claims. Well, we're willing to testify that the
claim about Trump trying to grab the wheel didn't
happen well. How can you testify? Something didn't
happen if you. Okay. That's sort of like squishy
and subject to some kind of interpretation.
This is just like, whose handwriting is it? Who
wrote the note? And if she didn't write the note,
you know, people tend to to know their own
handwriting. When I look, you know, down here,
I have all sorts of cope. I have copious notes
on a legal pad. I can immediately see that this
is all my handwriting. If I saw different
handwriting, it would be very evident to me.
People tend to be very well acquainted with their
own handwriting. She said it was her handwriting.
Someone else is saying, No, I wrote that. Well,
let's figure it out. And if she was wrong about
that, we would want to know. Did she deliberately
lie about that? Was she confused about her own
handwriting? Which would be weird. It would
be something to figure out. But understand
that every aspect of this is that is being used
simply to attack her by people who barely even
know who she is. As an example, Sean HANNITY last
night seized on this entire handwriting thing
and he said, Did Katherine really write it? Her
name's Cassidy. They don't even know her name.
They don't care. They just want to attack.
Speaker 2: Bring in a handwriting. I bring
in handwriting experts and they
can determine, was it Hirshman or
was it the woman from yesterday, Katherine?
Speaker 1: Right. Was it Katherine who wrote
it while Sean? It was not Katherine who wrote
it because no one named Katherine is involved
here. They don't even know her name. But to
the extent that this is a substantive claim,
is it her handwriting? Is it someone else's? Eric
Hershman says, I wrote that. Let's figure out who
wrote it and then let's figure out what the
confusion is. No problem with that whatsoever.